so very happy to have arm and speak to
us about appleís I first heard about
this project from the pi-1 of us on an
observing her check for many years ago
and he described it like this I'm gonna
buy a half metre telescope I'm gonna put
a really large CCD camera on it and I
want to observe from Mon Aloha which
occasionally has well panic activity so
I'm gonna put it on the back of a pickup
truck
and now if you're dealing with anybody
else
in astronomy you just look at them and
say and you hired where and how long are
you in this but John Henry is a pretty
sharp guy
pretty crazy five Sigma guy too
and they came up with the project I said
John sounds good I like everything
except the name because the high-energy
physicists have already sort of cornered
the market on Atlas and he said I know
but I can't think of anything better and
it does make great sense so Harmon
please tell us about that
yeah thank you thanks for inviting me
it's always a pleasure to come back to
Berkeley I've many collaborators here
and friends and guys always nice to
catch up and come up with new projects
so yeah my talk today is about mainly
about Atmos but also about transients
full disclosure I'm not an afterword guy
I'm a training guy I do supernovae and
so I joined this project this big trust
like a small group of four or five
people when we submitted the proposal to
NASA and yeah so the main goal is to
find this SOS and I will tell you about
that but of course it can pick it back
and find lots of transients and I will
also talk about that so just like a very
brief history of CCDs and wide field
time domain astronomy since we don't
have but we have many non astronomers
yeah the advent of CCDs truly
revolutionized
the Astronomy so in the beginning of
some 90s there was a first CCD is very
small that they're put on the on the
telescope's and so it's now finally you
could get immediately digitized images
and that's actually how I got into
astronomy I was an exchange student in
Portland State University in Oregon and
my master thesis was about CCDs
and for my series I wanted to have a
couple of pretty pictures and I put it
on a on one of these Alex to hundreds
and I was like wow this is actually
really fun
I haven't University of Washington met
my you know later on advisor we hit it
off and that's how I switched from
physics to astronomy and I you know so I
did my class you wouldn't I was a
graduate students in the beginning of
2000 and so I just like hits the wave of
these new surveys that use these CDs to
you know find all of these things so you
know so the first CDs they were like
really small you had like this point or
to secure a degree areas you could just
like look at you know a few objects and
then when I started to do my project in
mm they were already bigger ones there
was a mosaic two at CTO and Kip peak
where like eight CDs and we were like
wow this is actually really big at that
time was pouring three square degrees
and then in recent years it really
exploded to you know seven squared
equals pan-starrs or taken three square
degree to the newer ones going up to
tens of square degree so within the last
15 20 years we really increased by two
magnitudes our our focal planes and that
really has helped us to to do a lot of
the science it also has made it much
more challenging you know as Dave said
yesterday 15 years ago there were no
there was no money for software
engineering for some projects and of
course SDSS was kind of like the pioneer
of this whole thing and now without any
without any good software engineering
you just don't have any trials anymore
so we went from like
you know I remember for the essence
project we pour down a computer with a
half a terabyte and that was like our
huge computer for our image conduction
and now we have petabytes of data so it
nearly has changed in the last ten to
fifteen years and it transformed in a
very data-intensive industry basically
so one thing that work that got clearer
and clearer that size alone is not the
only important thing so normally you
would think hey you know you have a
smaller telescope you just make it
bigger and bigger and bigger and that's
what matters however it's also as
important how BIG's your focal plane is
if it's just one are interested in
spectroscopy of a single object then a
bigger telescope is much better but for
surveys it's as important to have a
really big focal plane because you know
if you have a big telescope if only a
small field of view you're as good with
a smaller telescope in a much bigger
field of view and so this is captured in
the engine which is the area of the
telescope times the focal plane and so
if you look at these that's like five
years old so we don't have a PDF yet on
that but here you know as a different
surveys there's a telescope diameter and
you have so focal plane you can see you
know it goes from relatively small all
the way up to you know eight nine ten
square degrees and then you can
calculate this survey power and you can
see that for example pants laughs is
relatively high and the similar to
tech-heavy even they cam has is a much
bigger telescope so as I said we have
now we are in this area of this white
field time domain surveys and what you
do is you normally combine two things
you combine the time domain you look for
solar system for variable stars and
transients I mean you stack all of these
images you look for a static sky and you
can look at our galaxy to iconology in
our galaxy or
can look into the hi-c universe so trust
I will talk a little bit about Atlas
some of the asteroids and your as
near-earth objects that we look at and
then I will go a little bit into this
discovery space there are different ways
how you can make a discovery you can
have dumb luck and grab this opportunity
and that's what I did I mean I think
probably I'm here because I was at the
right time
it's a why place and then I actually
said like wow this is really cool and I
went with it and it was one lesson I
learned and then you can also do over
you know is that is a discovery and you
hunt for it and I will talk about that
with a killer Nova and then you can also
leech on existing resources you can call
it repurposing of resources to also do
discoveries so this is a material
creator or barrier crater in Arizona and
or 50,000 years ago and meet your head
and you can see I think it's like 200
meters deep it's a huge boom if you were
anywhere around there in North America
you got pretty much yeah you were in
dire straits so this was not like you
know with global thing but definitely
locally it it was it was no fun then of
course more recently there was it was
like a 50 meter a metal iron nickel
meteor that makes a big difference you
know of course if you have a very dense
object then we have a basically 50 meter
bullet hitting Earth you get something
like that if you have kind of like a 50
meter lose wobble thing or this like
board on ice and it could be a comet or
it could be an loose asteroid then you
have something like that where it
explodes in the atmosphere so this one
destroyed 80 million trees in two
thousand square kilometers I mean you
have to think about it was I think 50
times stronger than Hiroshima that was
like a big thing
there was no fatalities and the only
reason was it was in Siberia and you
know as you know not so many the density
of people in Siberia is not at high so
that was just luck you know I mean of
course you have oceans they can always
explode over oceans or more inhabited
areas but if this thing hits anywhere
close the u.s. it will be it will be a
lot of fatalities depending on where it
hits and then of course you have the KT
impact that is believed to have extinct
dinosaur and so it's it's you know it's
a big thing it's like a hundred seventy
kilometer in diameter it's here in the
Europe and Peninsula and you know I
think it's it's not completely
established but there's very good
evidence that this at least had a major
role in that extinction event and I
still remember that that was before I
was an astronomy and I was like wow this
is like absolutely amazing so they
predicted that this comet is hitting
Troubadour and of course you know lots
of telescopes we were putting the too
much tribunal and indeed it's you know
it got disrupted before in several
pieces and then you had like this string
of comet pieces hitting Jupiter and you
know I think the errors probably fits or
close to fit in one of these explosion
areas so there's also a uterine so over
the years a lot of you know it got more
and more attention than the 98 of course
we have like two movies addressing that
and so the first one is Armageddon and
you know of course story you have this
asteroid or meteor and you it it's
hitting us and what you do you have to
drill a hole in it and detonate an
atomic bomb of course
instead of like having astronaut trains
to drill a hole they of course use a
driller and put them into space it would
be really easy who do you ask who's with
us
of course I mean you know we have to
have a real man to do that and someone
like post woman's needs to have the
right equipment so you have a Mircea
orgy object and you have 812 horses in
there so basically if you start this
thing and you hit a bump of that size
you're lifting off and you're gone yeah
but then this asteroid was depicted as
like having this needle sharp rocks when
you're bombarded all the time this base
bust you don't have needle sharp walks
you know you look like the moon it's
like craters and lots of dust and stuff
but last but not least you know only a
good guy can stop a bad guy they had to
have these guns on this wall was when
they said were sent into space I mean
it's like yeah of course
so I don't know I mean pretty much every
single stereotype they could come up
with they put in this movie yes there
was a Simpsons episode that was just as
realistic and yeah every stereotype and
everything that could belong
scientifically they did wrong yeah so
the impact was the other one and that
was actually much more sound
scientifically and you know you of
course you have some monster wave I mean
it would be what I catastrophic tsunamis
means out if something like that would
happen and so the attention to these
things to this this possibility of these
events was really growing in the last
few decades
then of course menu or have one asteroid
flyby at a distance of the moon
it gets all hyped up in the press but
you know I think this is just like what
we have to do this we have to you know
sell what we are doing it gives us a
funding
then the real game changer was turbines
in Wausau about five years ago video of
that asteroid in Russia barreling toward
Earth in forty thousand miles an hour it
exploded into pieces 19 miles above and
25 miles south of the city of
Chelyabinsk people thought it had missed
them entirely until a minutes later when
the shock wave arrived shattering glass
crushing doors not me some people write
off their feet more than a thousand were
injured how much warning did people in
Chelyabinsk add none yeah so that was
just at the time when we actually built
our our system when we build Atmos Atlas
so that was a relief that was definitely
also a boost for us and so that was our
idea right from the beginning to have an
early alert system that if you have some
of the smaller ones you can at least
give a couple of days or at least the
day warning and if you have some of
these bigger ones that it goes you know
to warning from one week to for the real
big ones like months for years so here's
kind of like I was really impressed by
it because it kind of like gives you a
scale so you have this nearly single
thousand objects are there are exercise
of Tunguska and two lemmings and these
are a lot and we only know about 1% of
these it's really a small number so here
is a KT event B it's very unlikely we
miss one of these really big ones be
normally known I mean it's a very small
chance that one of them BD slip schools
and and would hit us without knowing but
these ones here you know if you think
about to goose car something higher than
that and there's a good theory if we
only know 30 percent so there's a lot of
room for improvement
and a lot of work that you still have to
do and you know those 992 Spaceguard
survey reports said like okay we want to
have 90 percent of the NEA s that are up
up to one kilometer and that's basically
where we are right now and I think they
actually know above that this in the
recent decade yes flat with mass its
flatness mass yeah I mean I mean you
know of course we have the usual
distribution where you have much more
small ones than the big most but I don't
know the number of in in mass but it
probably is like that you know I said
I'm not a asteroid scientist so they
have been asteroid service since I
started grad school and of 90s beginning
of 2000 there was linear I was a little
bit involved in linear space watch and
then the other more modern service like
pan-starrs that I also was a part of
Kalina Sky Survey and NEOWISE and so if
you look at the distribution of the
number of discovered near-earth
asteroids
it really has gotten dominated by
camelina and buy pants loss and now
recently by by Atlas so that was kind of
like we started about 2016 15 16 and we
are now one of the biggest producers of
these near Earth asteroids so it was a
project funded by NASA to find these
asteroids as uki is a truant andriy is
as Peter said a very energetic guy with
lots of great ideas and he really pulled
it off you know so the unit cost for one
of these units is between half a million
and a million and we are trying now we
have two that are working and they're
trying now to get a couple more
on the ground especially also in the
southern hemisphere yes so you just talk
about what it means to find and not lose
yes yes
so what any lures you need to have at
least four to textually to get to get so
of it you know so we have like in pants
stars and lots of the other surveys when
you have only one or two the textures
and some of the part of the service like
was a transients you you lose them you
know if you have only two detection the
uncertainty in your orbit is just too
high and even though you can send it to
the NPC it doesn't really help you you
need to have about four detections
spaced preferably over a couple of hours
and the issue is also that lots of times
you have chip gaps you have bad columns
in the detect bus and one of the
mistakes we didn't pan starts at the
beginning but we only had three or four
epochs and we had a lot of chip gaps and
bad columns so normally you lost at
least one detection and so efficiency
was was worse having for images then we
then having them later on five images or
more you have a smaller area but you
just are so much more efficient you
don't lose most of them and so we have
to change a little bit our service web
fee for pens loss as you accumulate a
catalogue is there a commitment to do we
have observations on that catalogue no
they're too many it's like if you if you
find a special object then it's it's
it's different like someone this
interstellar object that pencils found
that pass through of course use all the
resources you have on something like
that or if you would find something that
comes towards us then of course you also
trigger follow-up resources and say like
hey you know send out an alert please
confirm that you know this object right
now with the error bars it could
potentially hit the earth
so you do that for everything else you
trust kind of like you know if it's a
new one then you get registered as a
discoverer of that of the object and
otherwise it's just like add it to the
database and it normally gets linked
back to the previous detections and of
course as more detection you have as as
better as you orbit so lots of them they
are in a stable orbit and the only way
it could get dangerous is in the past
Troubadour or or against its against
your back to preneur or by by some of
the other objects and then they get
kicked out of the orbit and then
suddenly they are in orbits that gets
you near to us so why now no object is
known that it's predicted to hit us you
know but it can it's really good to
observe all of these objects and keep
track of them because sometimes a small
change in orbit once a long one could
get it get it onto an orbit that that
hits us and it's sooner we know it it's
better you don't want to do a booze
villus and you know explode it right
before it hits earth because all these
fragments when they hit the atmosphere
that still has a huge damaging effect
probably near is the same then if it
hits it hits you in one piece it still
deposits all this energy in the in the
atmosphere what you really want to do is
years before you want to send something
there and just like give it a little
kick and that little kick over a couple
of years in orbit will deviate it enough
that it misses the earth so that's kind
of like for the big objects that's what
you want to do you want to get it as
early as possible to to be able to
change it and for the smaller ones that
you don't have in time you want to at
least know where it will hit you know
even if it hits in the ocean the tsunami
it will create even if it's a relatively
small one can also be devastating
so that's kind of like the goal in this
ball game
and yeah so we go and observe the
visible sky which is about sleep hi
every other day maybe a little bit
longer it just like depends house of
arrives so if we have good weather we
just get all observable sky pretty much
also be down where's the telescope can
go every other day and that use this
port filled us which is a combination of
the G and R & R plus is where we go as
poor as possible to get a steep as
possible but we still consider some
color information so we have information
about variable stars or stars and other
things in the galaxy so here's the
impact the size and that's a fraction
found and so in gue skies here trapping
is here the discovery probability of
course depends on the size and the
survey duration you know so if you lose
a few days for for better that I of
course you what you you create a blind
spot the size really has a big impact on
how hides or objectives these small
objects tell me that 2030 meters you
just cannot see with a small telescope
like that like leagues before and of
course having a big telescope do that is
just like too expensive and yeah so the
large one ISM the you know kind of like
civilization kilos they normally see
them years before they would impact so
we continue to monitor we should be able
to identify them in time
is that based on a simulation I think
it's a it's a combination we added fake
sparse to the to the images then you
also look at known objects how soon you
find them when they're coming and you
put all of these things together and
they can you can kind of like get and
get these probability you don't want to
do it either or I mean you wanna you're
gonna anchor your simulations this with
some of the empirical evidence and then
you're reasonably confident yeah and so
here's this again see both simulations
and real data for 50 meter a number 40
meter this is like some warning time in
days so you can see like 50 meters
normally we should get at five days
before impact but of course it goes also
all the way to one or two days and you
do miss some especially some ones for
the Sun so Sun is your big blind spot so
that's like this code of like 30 40
degrees in the trans don't have any
chance getting anything that's coming
from the Sun so we are now working we
have both working on both so much
summits we have been pretty successful
we do have about 0.25 tell by Politis is
nothing compared to you know the real
atlas of the particle physics yes it's a
Haleakala and mono Lua yeah and so we're
trying to get to put one into Flagstaff
and we're also trying to get one in the
southern hemisphere we have some we
would get some money from NASA the base
is a construction cost would be covered
we need the commitment from society to
then do the all the facilities and
things like that yeah so the nice thing
is with with Atlas it has a relatively
big full use of maximum it has basically
you know nearly it has to hike second
pixels pencils has points to 5-bike
second pixel that's nearly a factor of
10
and that's the reason if you compare
this is like kind of like the Panthers
field of view this is the atmosphere
love you this is just one chip 10k by
10k this one's here are I think close to
a hundred chips and so the volumes the
data volume of this smaller field of
view is much bigger than this one what
do you lose this resolution you know
there's these pen starts we have like
one like second seeing with Atlas we
have to like second pixels 2.5 Eyck
second food is half maximum so yeah we
are completely under sampled which does
kill some of the science or we just
don't go as deep enough if you would
have higher resolution but you get to
this huge field of view that would be
much more difficult to get this these
better resolution and it also helps use
a diera volume we have much less sterile
volume effectively then we have this
pan-starrs which really helps a lot as
well so you know different systems are
good for different things you don't you
will not do any high-redshift galaxies
science with this Atlas you use tech ham
or pan-starrs or hyper supreme cam and
but for this it's really good and in
there finding a lot of also a lot of
transients in the near universe like low
redshift ones so here's a comparison
again between pan-starrs an atlas or
atlas is just like doing the whole thing
that is visible besides the part that is
covered by the Sun whereas atlas in a
given night it's just like doing this
more pencil beam surveys so we are
finally starting everything is running
well we have the whole asteroid stuff
under control now this is going really
well
we have been one of the most prolific
discoverer of supernova in the last one
or two years assassin is another one and
PDF I think and pan stars are like the
the big four right now in in that game
we have discovered a hundred 30 años
so
every other night we probably find a new
one in a given night about 15 known ones
so you keep track of all of these near
Earth asteroids and we have now this
catalog of about 200 million stars and
each of these stars has about 200 about
12 detections per year per object as a
media some of them have 400 some of them
have less but I mean that's a really
nice photometric catalog down to a depth
of about 20 so I have trust got this
variable catalog a test a CI I'm betting
it right now to make sure everything is
okay and the goalie equipment between
truant Andre and and us is that we will
make it public in you know as soon as
possible probably in a in a few months
we do wanna made it if anyone is
interested what I have a look and just
like you know it's always good to have
real scientist Lou bitter yes yes yeah
absolutely
presumably for metric calibration is not
so the nice thing with pencils is we
have noticed really nice photometric
calibration all over the sky that's what
we're doing is we just use pan-starrs
to make synthesized catalogs and then
use that so actually one of my portrait
at SDC I have just got money for that to
hire someone and I heard someone is to
do the photometric transformation from
pan-starrs to all of these other big
Telus like most common telescopes they
can everything you know and then make a
database that has just an object that
are built that it's for automatic
calibrations in all these different
synthetic passwords so if you need if
you have taken images and you want to
have a quick calibration you just go
there grab the stars star galaxy
separation has already been done the
transformation has been done it will be
published in a paper and then you can
just go with that
this will be probably a better
photometric calibration than you can get
this school into Stanislaus so that's
also one thing that in the next few
months I want to I want to get out how
near is near hmm how near is near or
what's near in the earth object oh I
don't know what the definition is I
think that if Nisshin is that it costs
orbit a storm distance and most of them
are never really getting you know if
that's not real disturbing disturbance
of their orbit they will always this by
I mean it's it's a small target you know
if you think about the earth it's not
very big if you consider how big it's a
solar system is and and then you have
these you know two hundred thousand or
three thousand objects it's actually
very sparse usually people don't start
freaking out until it's like ten I mean
anything it is not closer than the moon
you know and even then it's it's still
that's a lot of space between the moon
and Earth so I mean it really gets hyped
up you know of course you have like this
asteroid and you know it will it will
miss us to 99.9999% and Hannibal said
sure and then subquest is doing some
saying and then it dies down because
it's just like business by a big deal
the at a big distance but you know the
other side we do want to keep track of
these things it will happen at some
point
okay the unexpected so this will be not
about Atlas data this is like in a
different theory I was involved this it
was a microlensing server server v2 was
a MC this is a mosaic camera on CT I all
and so we were looking for this
microlensing where you have you know a
back one store you have some kind of
type object in in front it bends the
light and you see this short widening of
the star caused by this destroyed object
so that's one way to find potentially
dark matter if it is in this compact
objects and so I did this this reverie
that was kind of like my thesis project
and then I did it also for it's a big
first years of my postdoc and that most
is one area where we just got a huge
amount of followers ten times more than
in any other field and you know you have
to go through all of these other words
it's really annoying and I was working
this on a quest you and then a lot of
postdoc and you know things were flying
by and was like yeah man I'm like this
is really annoying what is it it they
look strange it looked like this blobby
things and then I got this email form
from my photos autocrat soon it was oh
man look at this I pop up the whole
image and it looks like this you know we
were like what is that you know you have
this beautiful wings this is actually
these are like sweet amplifier so this
is like several Ike minutes on each side
so this is like a huge these wings there
and you know we are just like Neos
beginning postdocs passivated no clue
and we were like you know just casting
what it is and what's going back and
forth and then we send it out to our
collaboration and they actually didn't
know it first either they like a half
half an hour later someone says like hey
isn't supernova 1987a there and on this
slide a course of supernovae 87a and of
course and these were the very very
light echoes that were discovered you
know in in in 87 like you know 15 years
ago and we rediscover so just like very
quickly what are this light echoes this
line I goes
trust this scattered light of a dust
filament so your supernova 87a here you
have an observer here the effort I make
pass but then if it goes a different
pass gets reflected here it's a longer
path lengths and of course is arrives
later and if you have an ellipse the
bows the supernovae disseminate observer
it's in the focal plane so path lengths
from one focal point to sir loops to the
other focal point is the same so that's
there is a surface of equal arrival time
so when you have a - treat you see the
light the scattered light it's in the
section at a given time it's in the
section of this ellipse that corresponds
to this time since the explosion so
that's a reason when you look at the sky
you see the cross-section between a dust
sheet or filament and this ellipsoid
which is a wing that's the reason you
see these wings and if you have the star
sheets at different distances you have
wings of different radii and then a
little bit later
your ellipsoid is a little bit bigger so
your wings are getting bigger and if you
look at 87a and it's like a cuz it's
exactly what you have you have these two
wings that means two different - sheets
in front of 87a so it was kind of like
this you know was kind of like a cool
thing we rediscover it and then we put
it away
and then this time we found these other
things and they just looked like 87 a
slight echoes but the very depth at very
different places and they had a much
lower apparent motion and you know we're
really really busy with our survey and
so we put it into our attic where we put
all objects we don't have time to really
deal with but we don't want to lose them
and after like one or two years I've
been back and said like okay this is
like you know let's try to figure this
out and so when you have like echoes you
have these wings or like let's move away
so if you want to know the source you
just extrapolate backwards
and that's what I did so here's like so
it's not image template image and this
is five years so you can see after five
years it moved a few like seconds and so
I just kind of like fitted these light
echoes calculated so orthogonal and then
extrapolate backwards so these are like
the difference images between later
epochs and the previous epochs or all
static objects all the stars are
cancelling out I subtracted out and what
you're left is a difference Flags that's
the reason you see the s+ flux as a
later airport and as negative flux is a
previous sample and so I extrapolate
this backwards and then over product it
on the LMC and I tell you it was it was
really like this discovery sing you
right start it's the first thing I
didn't do it electronically I just had a
sheet and I kind of like do the arrows
and I was like oh this is kind of like I
I started with this one here and so I
caught like this half circle and was
like this gets exciting and then I had a
few for me I was like okay now it
doesn't make sense anymore but it turns
out that these are the light echos of
three objects and so the next thing was
what is it so I all but plotted there's
no way in green and that was like in
order I was one here and here but it
wasn't kind of like a full hit and then
when I over product the supernova
remnants it all made sense these are the
light echoes of this old four hundred to
a thousand year old supernova so what
you can do is you know you really see
the light the scattered light of these
old events so you take a spectrum and
you get the spectrum of this old
supernova it's a two time machine it's
as if we have a telescope five hundred
years ago and then you can compare these
spectra and I subtracted the continuum
you can compare it to your templates of
supernovae that you know of and you can
even identify a subtype of supernovae at
war so there was no voluminous type on a
supernova
so it was really cool so we're like hey
if we can do it in the LMC we can also
do it in our galaxy and so I meant
look for the light echoes of Cassie and
Tycho and indeed we found them here so
here you see again this vector plot if
you ever watch all of this vector for
giving cool it's here so tygo is here
because a is here
it was just like perfect and I Iran is
that that was that was really a lot of
fun and so he cuts back for the cows at
all for all the lab our like a coal and
he did the same of the Whizzer with a
supernova in the LMC and since then this
has been a huge amount of fun light
angles are the only thing where you can
look at the same astronomical object
from different directions and so we did
a study of symmetry in cos a we have now
spectroscopic time series of Tycho and
epic RNA was a greater option and we can
also now get the distances so this whole
thing you know I have a whole laptop
talk talking about all the science
static that you can do this this one yes
yes who cares about it but it's part of
the instrument thank you I mean you can
get to the thickness of the best that's
one of the side parameters you have to
fit you do this and actually to really
equity and I found that the sickness in
the LMC is significantly higher than the
one in our galaxy but yeah it's just
like too much things to do okay changing
gear a little bit it's a hunt so we have
seen everybody knows about cavitation of
waves
it was just like absolutely awesome I
have enough time to source a movie
we have LIGO and we go we found the
first cavitational waves about two years
ago it was really a beginning of a new
era and that you know if you look at the
signal nobody expected to see such a
huge signal is the first event the
second event if you look at the same
plot
it just looks like noise I promise you
no but because really lucky if it was
like this really you know high signal
noise event then everybody was like
absolutely astonished
of course you don't expect
electromagnetic counterpart for a binary
black hole or only a very weak one so
the holy grail in a way is to find this
electromagnetic counterpart for Aquila
Nova and so it's just like a very quick
little movie so if this two neutron
stars just spiraling in the started to
shop each other tightly deform this disk
of debris and then at the end they put
you with a gamma-ray burst so that was
kind of like some portal and everybody
was like so you know that could be
something to discover and it's not like
the unexpected will just stumble upon it
like me but it's like hey you try to get
this and discover it and so the idea was
that oh we will not find one until I go
find things to about to make up are 650
200 then the expectation was a really
faint and you can only do it this this
big telescope if you find something like
this closer than 50 mega parsec that's
like where it's really get getting
interesting together they are so bright
they can do it mister small telescopes
and in early August just two weeks
before it was discovered there was this
conference about kill ANOVA and and they
had a range of they asked when do you
think will be the discovery year of
killing gamma 2017 0 like really Co 2018
one single one everybody saw this 2019
or later and yeah so that was like you
know everyone's like yeah we still have
time to get everything set up then the
first thing happens in mid of August
there were a very go started to really
work
that's the third detector and this me
attacked us you have a much better
localization
so they found this this binary black
hole where they had this first signal by
viago and that changed the area from a
thousand square degree to 60s correctly
so two things were important here
Virgo worked that they knew it actually
look because a relatively low signal
noise but it actually worked and that
was two weeks before the end of that one
of this year so everybody was like wow
that's our last create a tiger and you
know now we have to wait a year and then
three days later this happened and it
was just absolutely amazing so camera
there's a gamma-ray detected by Fermi
and six minutes later there was a single
detector by the new in small signal
detected in I think it was in Hanford in
Livingston they had a glitch so I don't
have a thing but you have this this
really strong electric signal here and
so it was flat that's not reliable so it
was only a single detector detection of
this final Newton's law so now imagine
you are at Stella or like at the
detector you get a single detector a lot
you know at the same time because I was
a gamma-ray burst
they have never before send out an alert
with a single detector it was always
like hey you need to simultaneous
detection this both one and then you can
be sure and I have to say it took some
guts a half an hour after they are they
found it they send it out and was like
screw it it's only one detector in the
other the fact it looks like there was a
glitch but it it looks like it's there
this is real and we sent it out there it
was clear and say send this out or
handle plague news you know so this is
what happens I send it out and these are
like one of some of my collaborator so
it's Dave's a grad student and his
advisor and so mine was in Copenhagen at
every workshop and he actually took so
after noon
with his girlfriend doing some
sightseeing and then he gets this text
you know top everything check your email
so that sounds like a joke by the way
why was you know he was like okay you
know I you you and I wouldn't put it
past Dave to have a joke like that to
actually you know get him away and he
said like I might leave but if you're
choking it don't tell me bow I will not
be abused that's like a you advice a
saying that and he was just like I'm not
sure he Jesus man you know this is like
wheel and this video I mean things like
that happened all I mean we had like I
think they were I got 50 follow-up
groups or something like that so it got
you know at the beginning it takes a
while for them to get these localization
Maps all correct and that look at
localization map actually was jumping
around depending on what time and it was
not unsink if account and so Ryan and
Dave and Charlie they actually picked a
wide map and started to follow up and so
you had to two hours time before the
field for saving so that was like you
know we are just barely able to do this
so they event and at this time they
started observing so the didn't have
templates for these fields when we see
in telescope so they got it from deck
head and then Charlie looked at them
bleeding them by eye and said like hey I
found something so this is like the
iCard image and then this one is the
discovery image and look at this flight
object ago it was so quiet I think if
before any movie set like that first
kiddo know what will be played like that
you you would have been laughed out of
the qualifiers so about 25 minutes after
the image was taken they discover that
they immediately triggered Magellan time
it was like half an hour later they took
the first spectrum and then soon later
they were putting out the gzn and that's
like a lot of stories about that so
we've got very political and ugly but
they were extremely fast
I mean it really is like amazing and
that's the reason we have these two
spectra wife after one day otherwise is
they would have not turned around within
one hour it would have been absolutely
impossible to get a spectrum and it was
really crucial so that we got a whole
massive follow up there were several
other groups that independently
discovered it at the same time or like a
little bit later but it was it was just
like absolutely amazing this how many
telescopes there was a follow up after
one and you know I think you've probably
seen and we have had a couple of talks
about it I don't want to go into science
it's just like absolutely amazing - it
was the best or like the most important
astronomical discovery in like a decade
or something like that so repurposing
instrument I will just do it like for
five minutes very quickly I'm sure you
have also heard about the Kepler
telescope awesome telescope with a
purpose to find exoplanets we've heard
about it also yesterday and so some
colleagues of mine date the idea are hey
if you would get a supernova light go
off with this instrument it would be
awesome the problem is you have to read
out you have to designate which galaxies
to follow
they got accepted to follow Muhammad
galaxies and the for nothing and a year
later I was I gave a talk in University
of Maryland and after my talk this guy
comes up this is a professor and said
like hey you want to see something cool
answer like sure so it plops up his
laptop and shows me that and I was like
I was like you know I I started drooling
you know I was like holy moly
you know how did you get this so they
were a group looking for a GM activity
and they had former galaxies and it was
just small number statistics Brad and
Peter there are more galaxies they were
expecting one or two they didn't find
any they were looking for Adrian
activity and we actually found six
supernovae in this 400 so Francesco is
the other coop Truscott really unlucky
so I put all of these hoops together we
started to collaborate and it's
so what you want to do is this is like
curve when you have for example type 1a
supernovae you have this to lift us
whitewater it explodes if this binary
companion is a star then you will see
this excess light it's big in the
beginning of the light curve so let's
illustrate it here so you have a white
dwarf exploding and then it hits this
companion star and you see this shock so
what you see is instead of like long
like of a type 1a in this very first
days you see this excess flux and the
encasement
here has done a lot of modeling this
that they cool off already and so we
found three type 1a supernovae in the
first Kepler mission and it's amazing
look how smooth the like refers we just
don't see any signature like that and so
if these two models these two white
dwarfs merging and you don't see any
excess flux at the beginning or you have
a white dwarf and wet-dry and our main
sequence stars and you would see
something like that so this is one of
the best ways to get constraints on what
fraction of type 1a supernovae are
produced by which channel you can do
other things so these are the light
curves the early rise time of 2 type to
peel supernovae and then you compare two
models you can see here an excess flux
it's just likewise is so fast if you
normally cannot explain it this typical
model for type 2 piece so it looks like
that some or some material some shell
that got hit and gave a little bump of
excess energy into the explosion and
then here when you look really closely
you can see also a little bump that
could be a shock breakout if you look
closely and induce analysis it actually
significant I was very skeptical at the
beginning too and when you look closely
it is actually a significant detection
then the trial will died in in one of
the driver dies had only two left so
what they did was they use the pressure
from the sunlight as a third try walk
and that's how they could expand the
emission to k2
and the problem is you can only look in
two directions forward and backward when
you look forward the error is in the
field of view so they don't like that so
you look backward well then it's a field
that gets observed you can only see in
Twilight on earth we only get a Kepler
data after three months so you want to
detect this supernova in time to get a
spectrum so we have been fighting for
all kids who to get to find these
objects in Twilight and still get a
spectra and this year is the first one
that we got it was a type 1a and we got
that this Gemini at 2.5 air masses and
minus 14 degrees violet I mean I mean it
was really you know we were like sitting
there and I was like look it's really
quiet it was pulling those three and it
was like you know honking you know I
told Steve who isn't Gemini you know
just talk with or overweight on it I
know it's 2.5 Emma's they're not
supposed to go all the way down and but
you know just push it five minutes and
we will have suspect ah and and be got
it and you also can find some of his
exotic things that's the last thing so
in our our guy who does a reduction of
the light course you know we get some
new data after three months and he's
like hey here's a new supernova he sends
out this plot and I look at that it was
like a type 1a just looks like it and
then you look at the time axis and this
is 2.2 days you don't have supernovae
with the rise time of 2.2 days normally
I mean you know it's typical type 1a
supernova is 17 or 18 or 19 days and so
this is one of these really fast
transient we got it in one
epoch with Decker and just because we
only got in one epic we didn't click on
and didn't get a spectrum that was
really unfortunate so next time so that
was why did peak the next time we had
time that was not bad about was falling
this later and we just missed it so it's
just like papers just got accepted that
should come out in month or something
like that and you can compare it to all
of these other supernovae
so just summarizing you know we have now
be around this era of optical byte field
service
yes you guys have any like theories of
what it yeah we do so it's it's probably
a type won't be so it's like a very
compact star that explodes and it must
have gone through some mass loss a year
before or something like that and so it
has to shell so if we don't see it first
it explodes and then once into this
shell this 10 shell and then we
basically see where it breaks through
the shell that it goes up like that and
it's actually as quiet as the type 1a
supernova so extra little bit higher so
it is very white and you cannot explain
it this radioactive decay and that's
this whole cool of fast transient miss
pan-starrs we helped lay improvement
here to out did that and PDF found one
or two ins
superluminal SN LS and so this is kind
of like the idea now is a beautiful
light curve we can get excellent models
that fit really well this data this this
shell and the DV Khatami has standard
this damn case in here they're
collaborating on that and so you can
really constrain our the parameters of
the shell as well as the explosion this
curve what's this that's not an
exponential decay no it's not so I think
what you have is you have a supernova
that is very relative to faint
that is probably that bend off here and
most like this and all of that stuff is
it's a supernova going through the shell
shooting up and then passing through and
then it drops again so that's consistent
with the previous yes so actually should
have shown be we have now the figure
maybe shows a model and the model just
fits nearly perfectly you know it's a
it's it's been an extension
hmm there's there's no cataloging event
previous mass ejection or signature its
I think it's too faint so previous one
you know I mean it's like something like
every car visit radio option so you are
you like all the way down you know at
minus 40 minus 15 absolute magnitude so
few magnitudes four or five magnitudes
below and you know yeah be it's a
service didn't go deep enough I mean we
we looked up and there was no auto
transient there before unfortunately it
would have been really nice yeah yeah so
I just you know hope you enjoyed talk me
about Atlas I think any observers are
really important between Maps the solar
systems we get we have an early warning
system on place this atlas and several
other surveys we have videos on speed
dial
if something happens that we can do
something about it and my research
interests are mainly mister transients
that at the same time is there any
capability for doing like on on detect
on satellite decision-making about how
you might get a feel or down like David
so this Kepler no but here's the thing
that actually really good question this
tests a follow-up mission which is
actually 10 times smaller telescope but
they have two and a half thousand square
degrees of a field of view that they
weed out completely and so we don't have
the capital thing where you have to
designate what you read out you have so
for
image every 30 minutes if you would have
known that a few years ago when they
were still planning that we could have
asked them to actually save the two
minutes data it gets saved in a buffer
and so you could have triggered on on
you find the supernovae forms of ground
if it's buffered for more than one week
you could have gone back it's like hey
at this stem don't throw away so two
minute data
it's a we'd applied supernova we get a
two minute cadence like off and we could
have coordinated I mean it was one of
the ideas we had at the workshop and
technically it would have been possible
with space missions doing anything
significantly a significant change late
before launch is not going to happen and
so we talked to them it was just too
late but yes and that would have been a
really cool project to do so I have a
question that follows up on that based
upon David Starr yesterday which is the
survey design
what type of galaxies did you pick and
what thought went into the list yeah so
so this we were pretty successful at the
beginning and that's the reason they
were getting more and more open to have
bigger and bigger galaxies lists at the
beginning k2 we had like 2,000 galaxies
and our c16 and c-17 bf between ten and
fifteen thousand galaxies so you kind of
like mirage different information we go
to net get also known redshift galaxies
and so that's our primary list this is
how we start we get everything below 0.1
and then we go to pants task and also
photography from there and we start to
fill up based on and we just do it them
by by magnitude because we say like you
know it's more like dice as normally
it's a higher chance of a supernova so
this is not completely unbiased by far
trying
to maximize by the total number of
secret yes so we have and we have not
balanced this that we have it unbiased
however Ms tests we don't have this
issue test is so much pie though that we
should be able to find all supernovae
with Atlas and PDS CDF and assassin and
so there we should have a much more
complete sample and unbiased sample than
we have this campus Oh miss Kepler we
trust God's uh you know some low-hanging
foods and now with tests we can do the
more statistically sound analysis
questions so for the in the any any o
situation there any advantage to
consider satellite observation filigrana
and to cover that sign coma
I think that's yeah it's it's a
cost-benefit analysis it's really
expensive to put a satellite or to put
something L to and so do is adverse the
billions or lots of hundreds of millions
to put something there just for the
smaller ones that are getting hidden by
the by the Sun or you just like see like
well if it really comes from the Sun and
it's like twenty and wipes out a city
that's just like really really bad luck
so I'm I'm all for for putting it there
I would support it but I I doubt
Congress will go for that it's too small
chance never invested the most but it's
typically really another scale stuff
they're investing in right that's the
most
it's on the scale because you can really
do a really good job this is you know a
few million ten million dollar things
and yeah it's it's you know all right
looks like I'm going to get
[Applause]